[Music]
a few times in entertainment history
performers have died doing what they
loved
hanging out on movie or tv sets waiting
for the crew to set up the next shot
or while actually filming a take here
are some stars who kept on working
until their very last breath sliders was
a cult hit about dimension hoppers that
starred the unlikely combo of jerry
o'connell from stand by me
and jonathan rhys davis of raiders of
the lost ark
in september 1996 a 27 year old actor
named
ken steadman landed a small guest
starring role on a third season episode
desert storm while portraying a tough
guy named cutter
stedman was required to drive himself
and another actor on a dune buggy across
el mirage dry lake
outside san bernardino california while
the vehicle was equipped with seat belts
neither steadman nor the other actor had
used them when stedman lost control of
the dune buggy
it flipped over while the other actor
sustained little more than cuts and
bruises
stedman was seriously injured in the
crash he was airlifted by helicopter to
san bernardino medical center
but his injuries were so severe that he
was pronounced dead
not long after arrival vic morrow was
all over tv in the 1950s and 60s when
westerns and action shows dominated
it's fitting then that a major figure
from 1960s television would star in a
film based on a tv show from that decade
1983's the twilight zone the movie
the film consisted of three chapters two
remakes of old twilight zone episodes
and one original
time out written and directed by john
landis and starring moro
he played bill connor a racist who rants
about such feelings in a bar
before stumbling into the night and
facing a series of horrors
he's suddenly in nazi germany where he's
chased by ss officers who think he's a
jewish man
in another scene his last his living
nightmare becomes the vietnam war
where he's a viet cong operative pursued
by american troops
that sequence which was cut from the
film required morrow's character to
carry two children through a swamp
during a helicopter bombing of their
village an accident on the set during
the shoot
killed child actors renee chen and micah
dinley
as well as mauro landis and four other
crew members stood trial for involuntary
manslaughter
but were ultimately acquitted in the
late 80s and early 90s
a long and fruitful career for brandon
lee the handsome charismatic son of late
movie star and martial arts legend bruce
lee
seemed like a foregone conclusion he'd
already starred in a few action movies
and an update of the 70s tv series kung
fu when he landed the lead role
in alex poyos's dark gothic film
adaptation
of james obar's cult comic series the
crow
lee played draven a deceased detroit
rock musician who comes back to life
a year after his murder to avenge the
death of himself and his girlfriend
and to watch over his loved ones in a
horrific turn of events in march 1993
28 year old lee died when an otherwise
routine gunfire scene went awry
in capturing the moment when eric is
shot to death by a drug dealer
actor michael massey fired a prop gun at
lee which was supposed to shoot blanks
that firearm had been improperly loaded
however with a dummy projectile lodged
inside
when massey fired it sent the bullet out
and it hit lee in the abdomen
after six hours of unsuccessful surgery
he was declared dead
filming on the crow was shut down and
resumed a month later with body doubles
and special effects to approximate lee's
presence in his unfilmed scenes
as one of the most dominant and popular
comic actors of the 80s and early 90s
john candy compiled an impressive resume
of terrific films
candy was a big part of why stripes
splash
spaceballs uncle buck planes trains and
automobiles
home alone and cool runnings connected
so strongly with audiences
in 1994 candy headed to the durango
mexico area to film wagons east
a western comedy in which he portrayed
james harlow
a wagon master tasked with transporting
a group of miserable settlers away from
the wild 1860s frontier
and back to their cozy homes in the
eastern u.s
wagons east would prove a box office
bomb and a critical failure
scoring zero percent on rotten tomatoes
but far more tragic
is that it was the last movie candy
would ever make according to people
on march 4th 1994 candy filmed his last
scene for the movie
to celebrate he cooked a late night
dinner for his assistants then phoned
his two young kids back home in los
angeles to say good night
then the actor headed to bed and
sometime during the night he suffered a
heart attack in his sleep
passing away at the age of 43.
adolf caesar landed his breakthrough
film role in 1984's a soldier's story
as the mean and conflicted sergeant
waters for which he earned academy award
and golden globe nominations
he was over 50 years old a legend of the
new york theatrical world
he acted in more than 300 stage
performances
often with the lauded negro ensemble
company caesar did a lot of voice-over
work too
but after a soldier's story he quickly
landed major roles in many high-profile
mid-80s movies
including the color purple club paradise
and tough guys
however just two days into filming tough
guys a gangster comedy
in downtown los angeles in march 1986
caesar suffered a heart attack while on
the set
transported by paramedics to county usc
medical center
he was pronounced dead just moments
after arrival
he was 52. english performer roy kanier
is the very definition of a character
actor
a reliable and constant comic dramatic
and voice performer
caneer appeared in more than 160
projects in a career that spanned more
than 30 years
he's probably best known for his role as
mr salt the doting and beleaguered
father of bratty varuka salt in 1971's
willy wonka and the chocolate factory
he also played flunky planchette in the
1973 blockbuster adaptation
of the three musketeers kaneer reprised
the role more than 15 years later
for the return of the musketeers and it
was on the set of that movie where he
endured a startling injury
while shooting on location in toledo
spain in september 1988
the 54 year old actor fell off a horse
transported to ruber international
hospital
in madrid kaneer was treated for a
broken pelvis he was still under
doctor's care when he suffered a fatal
heart attack the following day
filmmakers had almost completed
principal photography at the time of the
accident
and the return of the musketeers hit
movie theaters in 1989
bearing a dedication to kineer check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one